what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to the room around up and i
have my cup of coffee with me thank god
because i'm recording this pretty early
and i don't know what i do without it
and as we get into our first segment
today a whole host of names have been
announced for phase five
in the mcu and rumors abound as to who
these guys are playing so as far as
we're aware this list is john boyega
henry cavill jody comer daisy edgar
jones john krasinski giancarlo esposito
and denzel washington now you guys can
probably imagine
everybody's kind of foaming at the mouth
when it comes to giancarlo esposito john
krasinski and denzel washington now when
it comes to john carlo esposito and
denzel washington really even john
boyega we can throw his name in there as
well the rumor going on here is that
giancarlo esposito is going to be
playing charles xavier and people have
been reacting to this with mixed
reactions some love it some hate it
what's really got me excited here as
much as i love giancarlo esposito i'll
watch anything he's in what's really got
me excited here is denzel washington and
john boyega because what it could do is
it could basically give us like adam
rasheer the blue marvel and that's what
i've been advocating for for a long long
time now fans out there have been
screaming that denzel washington could
play adam beshear and it would be
believable and it would the biggest
downside that i have with denzel
washington playing adam bush here is
that the marvel cinematic universe is
moving in the direction of hiring
younger actors to play characters for
longer somebody who can play this
character for upwards of like 17 years
maybe even 20 if they can kind of keep
them along and keep their character that
popular so as much as i love the idea of
denzel washington playing adam brashear
i would much rather it be john boyega
that he can play the character for
longer and assuming he doesn't have any
other contractual agreements there
wouldn't really be anything else getting
in the way of his ability to play that
character for the long term but
regardless as far as the john krasinski
read richard's rumor goes this seems to
fly in the face with our next piece of
news here which is apparently pin bagley
is being cast as reed richards in the
mcu now this is not absolutely confirmed
we don't know definitively if this is
the case penn bagley i'm not overly
against he's been in a whole bunch of
movies that i've never seen which
include like john tucker must die having
said that i still advocate john
krasinski plays reed richards i think
that needs to happen i think john
kozinski is read the way he played the
character in doctor strange too was
everything i thought it would be and he
would be a phenomenal reed richards in
the mcu he exudes that kind of authority
he's also a little cocky and arrogant he
has everything that you need for a
person to believably play reed richards
pin bagley i'm not 100 sure but i could
see him as maybe being doctor doom if
they wanted to or some other role
possibly the human torch but honestly i
want krazynski back as reed richards in
the fantastic four and i will never want
anybody but him i will go see other
people but him but at the end of the day
i will only want him to play reed
richards in the mcu but moving on to our
next bit of news here apparently elena
belova is going to be the leader of the
thunderbolts which is an interesting
change of pace in the comics it was
baron zemo undoubtedly this is going to
draw out people who are like blared
women in positions of authority blur
whatever i don't really care i think
elaine is probably the best person to
lead the thunderbolt she's got the
capabilities she's got the fighting
prowess and plus they're trying to build
her up to being the next black widow to
basically replace natasha romanov i
don't know how big of a deal this is
apparently u.s agent and baron zemo will
be on the team i guess they'll just kind
of be members of the team at the end of
the day it will still be cool right
basically a team of villains who are
brought together now i don't know how
far-reaching that's gonna be i don't
know exactly what their plot point is
going to be but there have been some
cool thunderbolts rosters that's one of
the things to know is that thunderbolts
has kind of been built by marvel as like
the throwaway team but on the comics you
had like red hulk elektra which probably
none of you guys care about deadpool was
on that team in fact i want to say that
deadpool elektra and red hulk were all
on the team at the same time together at
one point in time it's still a cool
thing right i'm still looking to the
thunderbolts project so on to our next
bit of news here dc fandom has been
canceled and before all you guys start
freaking out over the fact that
discovery just canceled another thing in
dc comics this is actually being done
because the coveted restrictions are
over and so what dc wants to do is focus
more on in-person events which makes
sense because dc fandom was designed to
be more of a digital event i mean as
this is not the biggest piece of news
ever but i do believe this is one of
those instances when something does need
to be said for all the people who were
just like yup this is discovery
canceling and dc's just you know totally
jump in the shark and this is the end of
all things right the end is nigh for dc
comics that's not really what what this
is this is actually them just kind of
shifting over to more in-person events
as opposed to doing digital fandom
events like they've been doing but
before we jump into the really really
really big pieces of news let's switch
over to gaming here for a second let's
talk about some gaming related content
as we always do here on the room around
up and the first real piece of news here
is that big chungus might be coming to
multiverses now for those of you guys
who don't know who big chungus is big
chungus has a fan base people love big
chungus it's fat bugs bunny and he's
supposedly going to be coming to
multiverses which lots of guys who don't
know who that is it's warner brothers
own fighting game which crosses over
basically all the properties they own so
basically their version of super smash
bros but it's going to be really really
cool and honestly i think seeing a fat
bug's bunny out there would be pretty
entertaining and honestly this is just
one of those instances where fans
organizing things in such a way can lead
to the creation of something awesome for
example for those guys who don't know
the multiverses game by warner brothers
was inspired by ultra instinct shaggy
literally there was a scooby-doo scene
where shaggy got into like a bar fight
and somebody put ultra instinct music to
it from dragon ball and that basically
led to a slew of just memes and even its
own subculture quite literally ultra
instinct shaggy has his own subculture
right and in fact like shaggy's kind of
referred to as like shaggy power it's
his own thing right it's really really
cool if you ever get a chance but like
literally the whole ultra instinct
shaggy thing is at least partially what
led to the creation of multiverses so
grassroots movements by fans they do
have an impact on the greater industry
and it is really cool to see it unfold
especially here with seeing big chungus
in multiverses
now our next big one is of course
another instance of ubisoft screwing up
so for those of you guys who don't know
there are when it comes to game makers
they usually screw stuff up and in this
instance ubisoft who basically came out
and said they were decommissioning older
titles now not in the sense that they're
getting rid of them but in the sense
that they were removing multiplayer from
those titles assassins creed far cry 3
things like that and while games like
far cry 3 are old games even though the
single player is still one of the
greatest single-player games ever made
for a far cry game the point being
actually i'd say it's the best for a far
cry game the the point being here that
there's still an online dedicated fan
base for those individual games and when
people saw that ubisoft was coming out
and saying like we're just totally
decommissioning and shutting down all
that online stuff the bigger concern
that people had beyond any multiplayer
capability was they would lose access to
their dlc now of course ubisoft came
back and said no no that's that's not
going to be the case because ubisoft and
ea they're the companies where they
would just decommission all that online
stuff they would take away everybody's
dlc and then it would make you pay for
it again and so ultimately it was again
one of these kind of grassroots things
from fans where there was just so much
outcry that ubisoft backpedaled and said
no no no we're gonna hold off for right
now we're not gonna get rid of the
online stuff they're gonna do it in
october as opposed to doing it in
september so they pushed it back by
about a month and they're also going to
let people keep their dlc so for the
time being people will get a chance to
enjoy the online capabilities of those
ubisoft games but they are going to go
away unfortunately so you know i guess
i'll have to find something else to play
so as we segue into our last bit of news
here on the rumor roundup we're going to
wrap up our gaming segment here by
focusing on spider-man which is
coincidentally going to be the last
topic that we talk about for the room
around us but when it comes to to the
spider-man game which is now on pc as to
be expected
modders are modding the hell out of this
game and you can play as all kinds of
different characters one the graphics
mods look phenomenal they look insane
and they're only gonna get better you
can play assault goodman which is cool
right that's really exciting you can
play as sora from kingdom hearts and if
you're particularly morbid you can play
his uncle ben's gravestone
which i have not done i probably will to
be honest and i feel like some of you
guys are just going to rush to the game
to download the uncle ben gravestone mod
and you're gonna play as uncle ben's
gravestone which is kind of hilarious
watching uncle ben's gravestone just
beat the hell out of people but
nonetheless right the modding community
is in full swing on the spider-man game
and i'm excited to see everything they
come up with but segwaying into our
final bit of news when our final our
final news tidbit here on the rumor
roundup this goes into the rumors that
people are claiming or confirmed but we
don't really know that anything is
confirmed that toby maguire is returning
as spider-man for avengers king dynasty
now i don't know exactly how i feel
about that it makes sense it makes
perfect sense that tobey maguire would
come back king dynasty is obviously
going to be a multiversal story that if
they want to build up the presence of
andrew garfield and toby maguire and tom
holland's continuing role as spider-man
in the mcu or at least as part of the
greater multiverse the better way to do
that is to have individual moments where
like andrew garfield appears in a film
or toby maguire appears in a film or tom
holland shows up in a film because what
it does is it allows those characters to
appear and to gain exposure and to even
thrive in the eyes of the audience
without having to be a side along to
like some other version of spider-man
because at the end of the day there are
just tom holland fans who don't really
care about toby maguire because they see
toby as being before their time there
are other people who are fans and when i
say fans i mean like five or six people
who are fans of andrew garfield
spider-man and then of course there are
people who are fans of tom holland's
spider-man actually to be serious and to
be honest with you guys andrew garfield
has a much larger following than he did
before but i think this is a smart move
now again i don't know this is
definitively true and the real big role
you'd have to ask here is what role is
toby mcguire going to be playing here
well i think in the end it comes down to
what tom holland's going to be doing
because the bigger gist here is that
with the kang dynasty film being a
multiversal story that will likely start
in quantum mania it'll build in loki
season 2 and then wrap up in the
avengers king dynasty storyline that i
think that this is going to be one of
those instances where we're going to see
a multiversal avengers team if anything
and i've been saying this before and in
fact we'll link a video to it and if i
didn't make the video on it i need to
then basically the avengers are going to
feel like the exiles but those guys who
don't know the exiles are literally a
multiversal team composed of people in
marvel comics each of whom just comes
from a different universe it's a
patchwork team of multiversal
superheroes and having that in the kane
dynasty film i think is going to be the
case i wouldn't be surprised if it was a
way for marvel studios to give us
characters that we've always wanted to
see team up for a singular film in some
capacity so you get tony maguire's you
get like his version of spider-man on
the team so the team has spider-man you
get maybe peggy carter who comes back
same thing with iron man this could be
our opportunity to get tom cruise's
superior iron man just one of those
things where it feels like a patchwork
team because it is like a hodgepodge
team i don't know that's exactly what's
going to happen but i think grabbing
people from across the multiverse to
team up and defeat king the conqueror is
a genius idea i think it's the smartest
thing to do especially if that team is
assembled by loki i think that would be
a genius maneuver and in fact i'm going
to make a video theorizing that this
week but having said that guys we're
going to bring this episode of the rumor
round up to an end thank you all for
watching make sure that you guys check
out our videos if you want to see more
theories and breakdowns and all that
kind of good stuff and i will catch you
all later
peace